- I think we better do well.
- Yeah. Yeah, it's gonna--
we're gonna do great.
- You don't think you're
gonna do well, do you?
- I don't. I don't think I'm gonna.
(suspenseful music)
It definitely could be her.
I'm gonna reserve
judgment.
It kind of feels like her skin.
It kind of feels like her
nose and her chin, for sure.
I'm gonna say maybe, but
I'm holding reservation.
I'm not saying yes or no.
I think this one's her.
I said the last one, her
skin kind of felt the same
but I think this one,
her chin feels more like I remember.
Her skin just feels a
little bit more familiar.
I think like the chin and
the nose are the giveaways
and this feels like her.
Again, I'm holding off
reservation until the last one.
I don't wanna dig myself a hole
and then, like, totally
be, like, "This is her!"
and then it could be
completely, completely wrong,
because I'm gonna be, like,
"They all feel like her,"
and then it's gonna be
like shot in the dark
and then I'm gonna-- I'm...
I'm gonna lose a girlfriend.
Holy crap.
I didn't know skin
could all feel the same.
Shit.
Oh, damn.
All right, I don't think this one's her.
I feel like the chin is too different.
Yeah, this isn't her.
I do know this is not her.
I'm gonna go-- I'm gonna say two.
(cheery music)
Oh, thank God! (Jordan laughs)
- You were so nervous.
- Yes, I was.
- You really thought
you might get it wrong?
- It's possible.
Victory is mine.
- Yay, we don't have to break up.
- No. (Jordan laughs)
- But you did it.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. Yeah! (laughs)
That was just terrible.
- All right.
- There we go. (laughs)